dr. John Zell welcome thank you start
with an experiment yeah if I have a tray
of cookies okay like in a meeting you
know you have you have cookies okay so
you have a tray of cookies and you have
a group of people how do we behave I
think they're gonna be four different
behaviors all of us have been here this
is this is the so-called Monday morning
meeting scenario or Friday evening
Scandinavian talk show scenario whatever
whatever but I think the hour for
behavior so the first behavior me okay
before before the plate even hits the
table I've already taken a cookie okay
and I'm munching munching away that's
the second type of person yeah okay who
you guys know who you are who people
long for the cookie they want the cookie
they love the cookie exactly whatever
interval there but for whatever internal
algorithm you don't pick the cookie up
but as a result I completely ignore you
for the whole program because I'm
thinking they're not the third type of
person it's the most annoying to my
opinion are the people who don't even
know the cookies have arrived they're
going my friends are like that what's up
with you and then the fourth of a person
now now this I think is the most
interesting sub a very interesting type
of person the people who eat the cookie
without knowing they've had the cookie
how's the cookie John and what cookie
cookie but I feel unsure and still you
don't know you don't know and I really
do think that those four behaviors I
mean it's a little bit haha but we all
know people ourselves or people that are
like that and so the question I'm always
asked is you know people think that
feeding behavior is a choice okay which
it is to some degree but though that
kind of behavior not even knowing it's
there versus loving it is it behavior is
it moral fiber no I think that's huge
biology that is actually underlying are
different responses not different
behavior to food
exactly and that's all you're going to
talk about we're going to talk about the
genes hmm we're going to talk about why
how important our
jeans are when we make this decision
mm-hmm
tell me about that it's it's it is a we
can call it craving we feel craving we
feel some sort of hunger or okay and you
eat for it for I think that's a very
good question so first of all so what I
study is I study I study body weight and
but what we now begin to know and I'm a
geneticist I study genes within the
entire field we now understand that when
we study the genetics of body weight
okay different people different sizes we
are actually studying the genetics of
how our brain influences our feeding
behavior like like what I've just
described okay
so we now know of over 300 genes that
actually influence why I may choose to
pick up that cookie so the feeling could
be pure hunger what we would recognize
as hunger going grumbly tummy okay that
could be the case it could be I don't
feel as full to different things
do I feel hungry or do I feel full okay
it might seem like the same is still
rude there is room there's very
different thing and then on top of there
then do I crave it so in other words do
I eat there are people for example who
eat when they're stressed and they're
people who eat when they're not stressed
but yet it's the same hormone it's a
common called cortisol why do we behave
completely differently to the same
hormone and that's because for some
people the eating makes them feel good
and those are just some examples they're
gonna be a myriad of that they're gonna
be people who are rather more subject
like yellow MS okay and so therefore it
will actually eat eat eat more but those
are the reasons why we might be
different in our behavior around what is
the purpose of these genes yeah you
haven't remembered that throughout the
vast majority of human evolution in fact
living evolution we never had enough
food okay to much food is a construct of
the past forty years okay too much food
before then okay you watch any TV
program in the 70s everyone looks skinny
they weren't skinny they were normal
right with you this is our low normality
has now shifted where all of us are
looking slightly larger
so but during the time when we didn't
have enough food okay any kind of
behavior which helped us drive us
towards food increased our chances of
survival just a little bit and so
therefore we were more likely to keep a
certain set of genes versus the other I
mean not everyone gets fat in this
particular environment but certainly for
some people that is a reason if the
genes have always been the same in a way
yeah why are we getting so much faster
these these days I mean since the 70s
until today it's a big difference huge
difference and and I completely agree
and I think we all know our genes
haven't changed we haven't suddenly
evolved the second head so you know
genes have our genes have have
maintained the same but the environment
has changed we were designed to survive
in a feast famine scenario okay
antelope no antelope no antelope
antelope okay and we have anted up all
the time feast of feasts become toxic
it's kept us alive in the feast famine
is now toxic in the feast feast
environment okay I I left the biscuits
here attention which which type are you
what are the four types what a biscuit
what were you saying I'm thinking about
the cookies you are
this is a this is a situation where you
have cameras if you if we didn't have
the cameras around
I would certainly have them but it's
also interesting because this also
affects like fashion like back in the
day when it was hard to be bigger
because there was a lack of food then it
was in fashion to be you mean you see
they saw on painting so these very
voluptuous women who were today would
have been considered too big because
today it's hard to be skinny so that's
why it's in fashion to be skinny that's
I think it is a shifting it is a
shifting environment for sure about to
say I'm too short for my weight what if
you won't change if you if you're not
happy with your weight what should you
do then let's put it this way if anyone
tells you that that they have an
effortless way of losing weight they're
lying
capital L if anyone says that I have a
magical plan if you follow it for sure
you lose weight
alright lying so I think I think what
happens is as long anything which gets
you to eat less which which which helps
you not pick up the cookie you will lose
weight on but but is it I don't know
have you ever been dieting oh yes I
think I've tried every diet during my
teens and early 20s I think I stopped
dieting around 30 but before then I've
tried the stewardess diet the pineapple
Diane what do the Weight Watchers my
brother did a diet in when he was at
university that was called the six eggs
and one bottle of wine diet he actually
ate six eggs and drank a bottle of wine
and yes he did lose weight he was very
drunk all the time but universities no
one noticed
so which diet is this an answer to the
question is that there are some guys
that are complete BS upon me but but
they are but a lot of diets actually do
work if you can stick to them so the
diet that works is the diet you
stick to and that is gonna differ from
person to person that's the yeah so the
whole point is that you you have to diet
for the rest of your life correct what
about the five two dimes the 5:2 diet is
a very effective way for many people
actually many millions could use it of
reducing your calories okay the physics
the the critical question to ask is does
it it doesn't give you any more magical
qualities beyond the cup beyond the
weight-loss evidence in animals and
what-have-you indicates plausibly high
quality human studies are yet to be done
but given that we were in a feast famine
scenario for for a long time in our past
would would I be surprised that the 5:2
diet had some additional minor metabolic
benefits beyond calorie loss probably I
wouldn't be surprised
okay let's say let's say you don't find
your diet you you can't you can't find a
diet and stay away then you have
liposuction so okay okay so so the short
answer is lipid suction is the stupidest
thing in the world you can do okay for
cosmetic reasons there are reasons you
might want to do a medically the longer
answer is this
I think people misunderstand what
happens when you gain weight or lose
weight people think you gain fat cells
and lose fat cells not true
your fat cells are like balloons they
get bigger when you gain weight they get
smaller when you lose weight and the
safest place to store fat is in your fat
the problem is when the fat is no longer
in your fat it goes to your muscle your
liver it causes all kinds of problems so
different people there this is the
important thing there fat cells can
expand like a balloon to differing
amounts before they leak the fat okay so
famously East Asian people Chinese
people or South Asian people Indian
Pakistanis cannot get as large before
they become ill okay because our safe
fat carrying capacity is different
whereas Polynesians famously white
people okay can gain a lot more weight
so if you actually because of our safe
fat carrying capacity all right now if
you do liposuction what you're doing
okay fine you may have a good behind
right after when you're done but you are
removing safe fat caring
it's the dumbest thing in the world you
can do the problem I guess with health
it doesn't always equal to beauty in in
in in the way we look at beauty I wish I
could look like Brad Pitt okay but any
number of different genetic problems can
fight against that so I think we got to
think about health rather and weight and
I think liposuction is a modern
phenomenon which just shows everything
that is bad about what we view off body
weights and what we view of health to
lose like a lot of weight a couple of
times per year I'm gonna explain why I
ask it my husband is an MMA fighter so
about two three times a year he needs to
cut a lot of weight for a fight so he
does this regularly 2-3 times P he loses
maybe around 10 kilos is that dangerous
or is it I think here it will be the
first thing that is dangerous is to be
an MMA fighter I think more importantly
is how he's losing the weight I think
there are gonna be some people who this
is probably not a great idea largely
because of the way some of these people
will lose will lose the weight okay and
in order to do that your your husband is
clearly fit I mean they eat a lot of
rice and salmon and chicken for like
three months so that's fine then that's
a perfectly you know but there are some
people who do it by going on the 7 day
water fast or something it's really five
hours exactly Oh Yuki oh you know
there's any number of different ways of
doing it which then become dangerous
what if you're carrying a child can you
can you manipulate the child's genes by
watching what you eat or what you you
can change how your child's genes is
turned on or turned off this is called
epigenetics okay what what you do and
there is no evidence okay certainly for
for for women who are pregnant where you
just have to be thinking about having a
baby okay not I'm not not actually even
going through the act okay either male
or female and your lifestyle how much
you eat okay can actually influence your
sperm or your egg
pass on a minor risk but still a
measurable risk to your to your
offspring so can you pass on your sins I
guess it's the question that you're
asking and to some degree I think
probably probably yes I mean I it's it's
high-quality human studies still need to
be done
who's gonna participate in these studies
but certainly from from from animal
studies and from a first principles
biology perspective I think the answer
is likely to some degree yes Charles
it's been fascinating thank you so much
for being here tonight
thank you very much hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you